my name is Peter Leonard and I serve as
the director for the did
lab at Yale University Library and I'm
very pleased today to be able to welcome
all of you to the lecture hall in
sterling Memorial Library for what we
hope will be the first of a series of
symposia Beyond Boundaries symposium on
hybrid scholarship at Yale University
this symposium which was organized
between the Yale steam group in the Yale
digital humanities lab was mainly
organized by cafe DeRose our outreach
and engagement manager at the digital
humanities lab and we're really excited
about bringing all of you in the room
today to hear a lot of interesting
stories a lot of interesting projects a
lot of interesting perspectives on the
question of hybrid scholarship I think
what's most exciting to me about today's
events is that you're going to hear from
Yale ease at all stages at all sections
of the life cycle you're going to see
here some senior professors talking
about what hybrid scholarship digital
humanities and stem and arts and
humanities needs to them you're going to
hear I'm going to see some presentations
from pro stocks you're going to see work
from graduate students as well as some
really exciting work from students in
Yale College the newest scholars that
Yale has welcomed onto campus as I
mentioned before this event is
co-sponsored by the digital humanities
lab and the gale steam group and i'm
actually delighted to be able to
announce a gift from barbara and rich
Frankie class of nineteen fifty three
who of course been outstanding
supporters of gales libraries for
decades and the reason I want to
recognize them today is that their most
recent generosity will ensure that the
digital humanities new home on the
ground floor of stirling library will be
a space that encourages exactly the type
of collaboration across disciplines and
methodologies that you're going to see
in today's presentation so we are so
happy that rich and Barbara are here
today and we're very thankful for their
support of this type of work with that
I'm going to turn us over to the first
of our events today which is a well yes
that's
there's no better way to recognize their
generosity than to go right into a
series of exciting lightning talks of
the types of scholarship that we hope
the digital humanities lab can be
successful in supporting and we know
that the undergraduate steam group is
excited about so we're going to hear
from a suite of presenters I'm going to
introduce them by name only they're
going to tell you their affiliations and
their research projects and we're
starting alphabetically with Anya Adair
will be giving a 7-minute talk thanks
very much the first thing I have to do
is switch this over and to prove my
digital humanities abilities let's see
how I go with doing this
thank you
perfect my name is Anya Adair as peter
has said and I'm a fourth-year graduate
student in the Department of English
language and literature and I want to
talk to you today about project-based
learning XML and the tei and the uses of
digital tools to teach traditional kinds
of scholarship in a non-traditional way
so to begin with traditional scholarship
any student wishing to work with the
pre-modern material of written culture
has a great deal to learn they have to
know Middle English Old English some
Latin certainly some French simply to
read the texts and then there are the
basics of palaeography the study of
ancient handwriting and code ecology the
study of the codex or manuscript book
both needed to make sense of a
manuscripts letter forms and physical
features reporting on all of this
requires reliable transcription and
reliable cataloguing within the
appropriate manuscript conventions every
new artifact demands some new expertise
a little art history for the decoration
linguistics to place a texts particular
dialect a passing acquaintance with
liturgical cycles to understand a
calendar manuscript study confronts
students with a range of scholarly
challenges often so many challenges that
serious work in the field is not
undertaken at least until graduate study
and often quite advanced graduate study
or even after graduate study through
some mysterious and haphazard process of
apprenticeship this is all the work of
the textual scholar and editor someone
who can go to a series of dusty
manuscripts and reconstruct from them a
readable version of The Canterbury Tales
and now and now to new scholarship
introducing digital manuscript studies
training students
new digital methods of text encoding is
another challenging proposition teachers
can expect a classroom of students with
widely varying to pre requisite skill
sets a few students may have worked with
XML many may not have even heard of HTML
on top of all these all those other
traditional skills that I had on the
last slide it can seem a step too far to
jump in and teach students some level of
coding before or while they try to
master the skills of the textual scholar
digital editing and the medieval
manuscript role is a project-based
two-day workshop run by and for graduate
and undergraduate students which seeks
to achieve the marriage of digital
humanities pedagogy and manuscript
studies and more it seeks to use the
very challenges associated with digital
tools to illuminate and make possible
the learning of traditional techniques
in manuscript study we throw complete
beginners right in at the deep end
crucially students in this workshop come
together as a team to tackle the
challenges they face collaboration is at
the center of the work participants work
together to produce an addition of a
manuscript role complete with digital
facsimile transcribed texts and catalog
data the hands-on approach requires
students to apply skills as soon as well
while they learn them and therefore we
hope to learn and remember them more
securely XML our old friend extensible
markup language is a general language
used for marking or tagging data in
whatever way the tag or prefers the TE I
or text encoding initiative provides a
set of humanities wide guidelines to
specify which tags should be used in
which textual situations offering a
common scholarly standard for creating
machine readable text for academic
purposes it's the latest teacher
of the tea either quite complex p5 which
has a comprehensive manuscript
description capacity that we use for our
work once a text is marked up using the
TI a stylesheet can display or a query
language search than now information
rich text in a range of ways working
with a team to transcribe catalogue
markup and design and interface to
display encoded text from the manuscript
is collaborative digital editing so the
question is how does add encoding to the
learning requirements help us to better
learn and better understand the textual
culture that is at the center of our
study before a text can be encoded Lou
Bernard rightly tells us it must first
be decoded the process of encoding text
requires it's implicit features those
things we just assume when we look at it
to be made explicit the same text can be
included in different ways for example
one editor might choose to mark the
lines of verse while another might
choose to emphasize the lines as they
originally appeared on the manuscript
page the decision to mark up a text in
one way rather than another depends on
the purpose of the addition and the
editors interpretation of what its most
important features are in our workshop a
whole session was devoted to a
discussion between participants about
how to encode the text they had just
transcribed when you get right down to
it all of this traditional work is about
making choices and having to encode a
text forces you to make those choices
very precisely here the choice of the
text we worked with a manuscript role
was central as you can see here this
text isn't all standard it's non
hierarchical and it's not neat and
there's anyone familiar with that XML no
hierarchy is absolutely at the center of
it and it's certainly
the center of the TI which imagines
texts to divide neatly into books and
then chapters and paragraphs and then
sentences and then words so getting
students to move right to the editorial
stage and to literally mark the text
with appropriate tags working within
this system that forces uncomfortable
choices to be made makes starkly clear
the intellectual stakes of the work
being undertaken each of those
traditional skills within this new
economy becomes a tool to solve a very
real and present problem and in the
urgency of these challenges posed by
digital editing tools the real learning
of textual scholarship takes place
thank you so much on young I'm now like
to welcome to students up next a yeast
will be on excuse me yes you'll be owned
and Peppa Gomez a sable thank you Peter
good morning um so as a speaker said oh
yes when I have been working appallingly
related with the young university or
gallery in which we've been trying to
create a conceptual map of the different
pieces that are exhibited this
initiative comes this part of the
student guide program which both you and
I are part of something that
distinguishes this program from from
other student-run guides and different
museums across the United States is how
interdisciplinary our approach is we do
thematic tours and in them we draw a
series of connections between our pieces
that the general visitor would usually
not make for example speaking on my
behalf my tour I start with an Assyrian
relief down in the medieval gallery and
then I go up to the contemporary gallery
to talk about a soul lay with wall
drawing so in thinking of how we could
have these connections be made more
explicit we sort of we're trying to see
how we could tag the different pieces of
the way in the art museum and create
sort of a network in which a visitor
could jump from one piece to the other
in a less conventional way our galleries
right now are organized by in in a very
traditional sense for example or
European galleries organized
chronologically but how could the
visitor break through the layout of the
gallery and have an experience that is
more interconnected the project
inherently had three three phases the
first one was the database how are we
going to create this index what ties are
we going to give to each work the second
one was was more related with the
visitor how is he going to see it how
are going to draw these connections
gimme a network this could be a tree map
and then finally the platform of course
where is it going to resign proly an
appt only
a website not in that stage point yet
the hidden the hidden gem of this
project is is actually in the way that
we've we've got in these these tags the
students actually write very lengthy
papers on each work there is to
conservation reports there Kurt oral
files for each piece and in using a text
scanner we were able to identify the
most rather than words here for the van
Gogh's night cafe you can see how the
top the top six or seven words are very
relevant unfortunately right now we
don't have n graham so van Gogh does get
cut it's something to work on in the
later stages in terms of visualization
though we have to we have right now
we're working on two two options here
showing an early early relation the as
you can see here we have three pieces
highlighted and they're connected by the
word religious for the Assyrian reliefs
and for the threshold in the specific
gallery that we did expect to see sort
of religious in them but for Ralph go it
wasn't so evident which sort of proved
that database component was working and
sort of these like unexpected
connections were occurring the powerful
part about the network sort of
visualization is that you can sort of
jump around very easily you can get a
sort of broad sense of the gallery of
the different words the problem is
already in this like quick sketch with
only five pieces that no one is pretty
does so in trying to think how the
visitor would actually navigate the
space in the gallery or how the visitor
in the website would would look at the
other different works from home we we
actually are right now working for it's
sort of a tree map mode of visualization
it would be a two-stage tree map to you
here on the left a quick mock-up for the
van Gogh and I cafe where we have a
this series of more relevant terms vengo
caller night table upon clicking on each
one of these towels so the visualization
would change into what we see on the
right side say we click in color then
the new tree map would be for the for
calling and instead of having attributes
inside of the each now we would see the
actual works of art this would enable a
visitor to go very wrigglers rigorously
from one piece to an attribute and then
either going back to the piece to look
at other attributes or moving on to the
next piece that he would like to visit
in the gallery now moving forward the
right now we are taking a very sort of
we're thinking about the visitor our
goal is for him to see the gallery in a
new way but this could also potentially
turn into something that is a bit more
academic and I think for a later stage
of the project our goal will be to see
how these tags can be traced back to
their original essay or to the original
cry torial file and so the visitor can
actually in front the piece see why is
religious important for the road thank
you very much thanks very much you now
like to welcome Roger Pellegrini or I'm
sorry totally got that wrong on
Stephanie Acevedo hi my name is
Stephanie I'm a fourth-year PhD student
music theory and today I'm going to talk
about my dissertation project so just to
give you a little bit of background
where this project comes from in music
theory there's currently emergence or
reemergence of what people call schema
theory and it's very specifically used
to talk about a specific type of
abstraction of classical or what I call
what we call common practice musical
tonality so you can see an example of it
here where you have
this a diagram of the well-known
Romanesco and so each oval presents a
chordal event and it has some
information about metrical position
about the melodic lines and what court
type of courts would be played and here
so this low musical example is going to
play the Romanesco and then a very
common use of the Romanesco which most
of you will probably recognize if I
don't accidentally click ahead
you
so that was a snippet of Pachelbel's
Canon so my dissertation um is
interested in looking at historical
practice or historical listening but
then kind of getting rid of the temporal
and geographical gap that would that
would arise from studying common
practice or classical music and of
course I can't put an eighteenth-century
listener into an EEG cap and study them
so I have to deal with modern listeners
the problem with moderate listeners is
that we don't just listen to classical
music we also listen to a wide variety
of musics pop rock whatever right so my
my studies actually looking at popular
music harmonies and also interested in
how those really might relate or be
similar or different to classical music
harmonies I have two phases the first
phase is a corpus analysis of popular
music to really get at the statistical
kind of background of what you know what
what the harmonies of this corpus are
and then a phase two which we an EEG and
experimental component so the first
phase which is what I'm focusing on
right now is a corpus analysis of the
McGill billboard corpus which is a
sample of the top 100 hits Billboard
chart hits from nineteen fifty eight to
nineteen ninety one and this gives me a
wide array of not only genre but also
types of music that we may not even know
anymore I've listened to a lot of woman
I'm like I've never heard the song
before but then there's also really
really popular songs and basically the
the assumption is that a lot of this
music represents kind of an ambient
tonality an ambient type of a pattern
and harmonic squamata that arise and
have possibly influenced even musics
that we might listen to now or that are
popular now so the corpus is
today's 890 songs and this is a snapshot
of what the text file would look like
for this song it's just chords but
there's symmetrical information and
there's also taggings for formal
parameters like introduction verse
chorus and so forth so the first stage
right now I'm looking at progressions
using entropy so this is using
information theory and for those of you
that are not familiar with entropy
basically looking probability P is
inversely related to probability so what
I'm doing is I'm looking at sequences of
quartz and finding spikes in entropy or
troughs and probability and delineating
segments based on those troughs and
using that I can find for current
patterns where there's a level of
uncertainty that marks a segmentation so
just to give you an example of the type
of thing that I'm finding right now I
found 705 distinct progressions these
unique progressions actually occur a
total of twenty-six thousand times in LA
corpus keep in mind that some of them
might be redundant or just variants of a
similar thing for example one of the
most common things that I found this
occurs almost 500 times it's a sequence
of seven chords and XYZ relate to the
stairs so X would be the same thing why
would be a different major triad in this
case and Z would be a different major
triad the orange shows the relative
distance between the root of these
chords so as you can see you have the
distance between X and y would be a it's
a perfect fifth and then y and z would
be a minor seventh so this is just an
abstraction of a possible instantiation
for those of you that are familiar with
music Roman numeral analysis we might
have a 1541 progression as seen here I
can further abstract this into a three
element loop
so as you can see XYZ would repeat again
and then I would exit the loop in the
little black arrow what this tells me is
a patterns of expectation repetition how
many times does this loop repeat and
then I can create a based on this
analysis i can create stimulate for
phase two which would be my experimental
setup i haven't gotten here quite yet
but this is just kind of a mock-up of
what it would look like there's a lot of
research done by stephan kolchis lab in
germany of EG experiments where they try
to find erp components based on
syntactic deviations in classical music
so this is an example what they're
stimulii look like a normative
progression would look like the one on
the top where you're presented with a
stimulus of say 1 4 to 5 1 but then a
deviation a syntactic deviation would be
something like you see in the bottom
where the cord of the last final one
cord would be replaced with a 2 chord
and this creates what we call an iran so
an early right interior negativity and
the brain which is a signal of surprise
so basically what i would do is once i
find my statistical the once i finish my
statistical analysis instead of using
these common practice progressions that
would use a popular popular progression
for my stimulii i also want to look at
uniqueness measures and familiarity
familiarity measures for the mcgill the
songs in the mcgill corpus and see if
there's correlations there to thank
thank you so much Stephanie so from
medieval manuscripts to art galleries to
music it's natural to move on to poetry
so I'd like introduce Roger Pellegrini
everyone my name is Roger Pellegrini and
i'm a senior english major in the
creative writing concentration for my
senior project i'm writing a long poem
that's partially written by a neural
network or very basically an artificial
intelligence program that's been trained
on american poetry yeah so if you'll
indulge me with a little audience
participation I'd like to begin my talk
with kind of a game poet or program one
of these was written by a robot and
another one was written by a human so
take a few seconds to read in the
samples and then let me should not let
me know by a show of hands which you
think is the robot and if you've heard
the human poem before no cheating all
right so who thinks that the first one
is the robot show of hands okay and who
thinks the second one is the robot all
right all right there's a little
confusion but I couldn't trip you up
first one was the robot in the second
one is Emily Dickinson before we move on
from this one I think it is worthy to
note though that the robot did learn to
rhyme so all right powder program I
don't know if this one will be harder or
easier but
people are still looking
alright who thinks that the first one is
the robot and he thinks the second one
is the robot I got you yeah thats from
song of myself and last one longest one
but quick reading lightning reading this
is a lightning talk so
okay so maybe you haven't had time to
read them it all bats who thinks the
first one is the robot second one is the
robot alright so that was kind of just a
fun little thing but I think there are
some things that we can take away from
this so the most human things are
usually thought to be the most difficult
to encode but as we just saw this kind
of artistic context can allow for a lot
of wiggle room just because of you know
how much is allowable in art now the
point of my project isn't so fool people
even though that is fun I'm more
interested in you know investigating
when the program does fall short and you
know in what does make human generated
writing human and I think this is
particularly important because not only
are their programs that sound like
humans but there are also humans that
sound like programs and I don't mean
that to demean Gertrude sign in any way
but just to say that you know you're
lucky that I didn't put this up there
for the game because I think that really
would have tripped you up right so given
that the question that my project tries
to address or investigate is at what
happens when an unusual human voice is
presented as human and what happens in
bringing the Raider towards the program
rather than in bringing the program
towards the reader and when does the
program fall short and when can you know
we kind of assert our humanity in a
sense so just to take a step back and
give you a sense of how I arrived with
my project I started off by doing some
kind of preliminary experiments with
song of myself because it was not under
copyright and I like Walt Whitman if
you'd like to go to my lovely website
and find out more about them
32 but the first kind of experiments I
did was just a random reordering of 14
lines from song of myself and then the
second one was a to Graham model of song
of myself and particularly this past
summer with kind of the Google deep
dream neural network pipe explosion I
got interested in taking it a step
further and trying to look at American
poetry as a whole and to see what can be
gleaned from it as a whole I used some
very convenient very free code from
Andre Carpathia to create a character
level recurrent neural network so this
computer program is taking in a huge
swath of American poetry and learning it
character by character and reproducing a
character by character rather than word
by word to create output that is
structurally similar to American poetry
in terms of my methods and materials the
just getting the material to train the
network on was a huge task and it was
really you know up to what was not in
copyright and what I could sort of
attain semi legally as a result the
neural network was trained on over a
third John Ashbery which probably
doesn't do much for its coherence
but to what I was stuck with then to
talk about a bit about my process the
most important parameter after creating
the network and to create the output was
the temperature variation in very simple
terms varying the temperature determines
kind of how closely the output will
stick to what it's been given so in just
visceral terms a lower temperature it's
kind of colder it's more conservative
and it will produce something extremely
structurally similar to what's been
given whereas a higher temperature will
be a little bit more chaotic and give
more diversity and also more mistakes to
give you some samples of the output just
given different temperatures with the
temperature of one very chaotic you can
see it makes a lot of spelling mistakes
the hell's of lecture pink I don't know
that means at a temperature of point
seven we kind of get towards something
that's a little bit more coherent but
very interestingly and this held true
across all of the neural networks that i
created a temperature of almost zero
produced consistently this phrase over
and over again which you know mites I
back to the pictures of how earlier it's
it's full of stars I haven't really come
to terms with that yet but that's
another project typically I took
something like a temperature of point
seven and then kind of pruned it a
little bit and gave it a little bit of
help before inserting it into my larger
poetic project so here you can see I've
kind of made it dramatically almost it
doesn't really make much sense but you
know that's really what I set out to
explore so in the end the neural network
kind of just excelled in moments it had
a couple of really nice phrases angels
despair to the stars why I soon do
nothing but
and and my personal favorite my spirit
was left prisoner to the special states
of metaphysical languages I think we've
all been there however in the long run
the neural network kind of lacked an
overarching structure kind of an arc to
what it was saying and it had a lot of
many a lot of you know the X of the why
of the sea of the a and it will often
just go on like that for a while which
is you know a funny impression of poetry
but for certain brief moments kind of
with human help I was able to use it as
a believable different dependable other
voice in my project and you know this
will be up to the readers of my thesis
but I think that in the end it ended up
making my own voice sound more human so
thank you very much
thank you so much Roger Michael Weaver
is next hi my name is Michael Weaver I'm
a PhD candidate in political science and
here to talk to you a little bit about
some might work for my dissertation on
public discourse is about about lynching
in the United States so this project
starts a bit of a historical puzzle I
think most people don't realize the
extent to which lynching was widely
publicly supported in the late
nineteenth and early twentieth century
southern newspapers routinely openly
defended and praised the practice when
they didn't used implicitly image that
to humanize the victims presume there
guilts and presented the mob as an agent
of popular sovereignty and actually many
northern papers picked up a lot of the
same language and repeated it again and
again here we have an example from the
New York Times doing just that but in
the 1920s and 1930s things had changed
quite drastically such that victims are
no longer dehumanized the press question
their guilt and importantly the mob was
criticizing more than that the press
really skewered political officials and
police officers that fail to intervene
and stop them up and bust uphold the law
and so my research tries to address the
question of how did this transformation
and public acceptability of violence
occur I'm not going to give you a full
answer today talking a bit about one of
the answers I come up with in my
dissertation which relates to publicity
and particularly the role that changing
technologies particularly for
communication played a role in creating
new forms of publicity for lynching so
at the turn of the 19th 20th century
there's a massive expansion in both
transportation networks such as
railroads communication networks like
the Telegraph and telephone and also
news services like this is it press so
here's an example of railroad stations
in 1818 across United States by 1910
it's a much much denser at the same time
you see similar changes in the Telegraph
so for instance this is the growth in
telegraph lines operated by Western
Union over the same period of time in
nearly quintupled all of the serve to
make the country much smaller this
reduce travel times to build people with
information and also created a new
national public that was easier to
consume knew that a national level what
does men is that the publicity of
lynchings was much greater and reached a
much greater and more geographically
dispersed audience so why does that
matter so I argue that by bringing news
about lynching and more generally about
certain types of violence to wider
audience you break news of lynching free
from the locality in which it would
encourage it occurred which means first
that the perpetrators lose control over
their narratives about violence so in
fact prior to this period of time most
national news stories about lynching
were in fact written by the local
newspaper editors where the event
occurred that's where the wire services
got their stories as these networks
become denser these local actors have a
less and less control what were the
stories they tell about the while is
perpetrated in their communities at the
same time does this news reaches new
audiences to sleep critically in the
north and in the West that were less
sympathetic to lynchers they didn't say
bye into the social structure that
upheld lynching is as a focus of form of
basically labor repression and racial
repression in the south at the same time
news reaching broader audiences gave new
opportunities and sites for criticism in
the South it was actually very dangerous
to criticize lynching african-americans
who criticized lynching could be
violently threatened or killed and even
white opponents of lynching to be
wrapped round of town or at least have
their homes ransacked or vandalized and
so this new form of new opportunities
for criticism ultimately meant that
lynching events could become national
scandals so that's my arm aggravated
short how do I go about testing this
since this is where I think I fit into
this digital team and has come workshop
so basically I've collected a lot of
data try to get a sense of both the
changing technological advances at the
time as well as how lynching has talked
about in the press so
important for this project is a sense of
which we're bringing big data to history
I'm working with several digitized
historical newspaper archives which
encompass well over 3,000 different
newspapers but the nationwide coverage
ranging from big-city dailies that you'd
recognize like Newark New York Times
Washington Post Chicago Tribune down to
small town weekly as freakin counties
you've ever heard of all over the
country and total this corpus of text
includes eight million plus issues of
newspapers and it's constantly growing
between a period of eighteen eighty in
nineteen forty and the greatest thing
about this is because is it that this
has been digitized or able actually to
search this content so for instance I'm
gonna be chosen for some results working
with about 1.2 million articles that
they make explicit mention of lynching
just the view size of this data look
like this is a sample over time as you
can see it's quite broad across the
entire country this is just an example
of what daily press coverage of lynching
looks like each time is a bubble that's
press mentions of lynching but large of
a bubble the more lunch the more press
coverage to the region that place you
can see the sort of temporal and
geographic pattern would you see just
really the whole country flight up as an
event catalyzes the nation the same time
I've also worked to collect data on
railroad networks I have yearly a Tubba
tween 1880 and 1900 on connections
between counties I'm hoping to extend
that forward to 1911 does a period of
rapid growth in which railroad basically
double in length during this time I'm
able to calculate the centrality of
counties to railroad networks as well as
travel time between them just to give
you example this is a travel time from
new haven county to the rest of the
country 1880 and again in 1900 you can
see the reduction in travel time it says
even more extreme for places like
Western Arkansas or Eastern miss up and
Eastern artists on Western Mississippi
where you see a lot of glitches these
changes may have much more so what do I
find so in short I test three major
implications of this argument first I
want to see that you should see that
lynching is more likely to be covered in
the press when the distance between the
lynching the paper decreases and find
that's in fact what happens if you get
further away much less likely to have
coverage I should also see that the
lynchings more likely to be covered as
travel times decrease even though the
geographic distance can provide us some
sort of a nominal anonymity for lynchers
more or less I find that these that
reductions in travel time almost exactly
offset the effects of distance almost
like almost perfectly and then the
coefficients of these models you also to
expect to see that I you're going to be
more coverage of lynchings when they
occur in areas at a more central
communication and transportation
networks so using two different measures
of network centrality we find that 10 is
the highest decile basically increasing
network centrality means you're more
likely to be covered under both two
major conceptions of centrality so let's
have key first step adduced my arguments
so it was next for this project the next
big question is does publicity in fact
produce more criticism one way to do
this is look at keywords and phrases
that correspond to various Pro
anti-lynching discourses which I've done
basically examine those Geographic
patterns I haven't had a chance of that
geographically but to poorly we can see
a major shift over time and particularly
during the height of the n-double-a-cp s
anti-lynching campaign from 1919 to
about 19 24 and one day you look at in
terms of geographic dimensions of
coverage we should expect to see that
the press coverage of lynching is more
critical when the papers further away
from the lynching particularly a place
without a history or culture of punching
next expanding this data besides just
looking at how well-connected your
counties we actually think it matters
how close you are to actual railroad
stations were to actual telegraph
offices so I've been work at a geocode
the exact location of lynching events as
well as the transcribing geocoded
locations of railroad stations and
telegraph stations for about the 1880s
to 1910 1920 s and part of this project
involves creating working with a grant
from the D H lab to create a website
that will facilitate the crowdsourcing
of the transcription
both both of these types of data this is
an example of what these pages look like
I've got a lot of them they able to scan
what the hell the library and so be a
project and what people can help
transcribe all these and the idea what
ultimately create maps that will
automatically update once Apple have
transcribed alludu location it will be
geocoded and add it to a map like this
which are right now only has two
endpoints the end we'll have a full time
series of where railroads were and
ultimately where telegraph offices were
during this time frame so that's it
thank you very much thank you very much
Michael and now on to grace pedda Gorski
hello my name is grace pedigo risky and
I'm a senior in yale college at a
computer science major my project was
yeah sorry a computational analysis of
images in the vogue magazine archive
which is available to anybody within the
yale community as a collection in the
library digitally so when i first found
out that the computer graphics lab
actually had access to this database i
started thinking about what could this
huge database of over 400,000 color
photographs and more photographs from
before that over votes enormous history
how those images could be used to study
some sociological trend that followed
from things that appear in graphical
media so first of all a little bit of
background about why vogue vogue is a
very old institution
and the scheme of American magazines
it's very influential in the world of
fashion it's been around for close to
125 years and it's been printing in
color for quite a while I chose the
start like the starting point for my
analysis in the year nineteen forty two
because that was about when I was
starting to see predominantly color or
low color images but not predominantly
black and white images these specific
the specific metric that I decided to
try to analyze over the course of the
magazine's history was the skin tones of
people that appeared within the magazine
both in advertisements and in the
fashion photography of the magazine my
hope was to be able to draw conclusions
regarding how the types of people by
skin tone who appeared in the magazine
could be related first of all to our
cultural standards of beauty who seemed
at different time periods to be
acceptable to put in a magazine that was
supposed to be showing beauty and beyond
that how especially in advertising
how the way that people were portrayed
the way that people were photographed
might either perpetuate or challenge
stereotypes so my initial reading before
beginning the project showed that
particularly in advertisement there are
some racial biases that definitely exist
up till the present day in who is
depicted how in advertisements the
studies that I read it specifically
talked about women and advertisements
essentially white women could be
depicted in pretty much any context and
pretty much any kind of advertisement
they could be shown being confident
happy in a family setting they can be
shown to look attractive sexy even given
the context and women of color were
usually not applied to the same range of
the same range of different types of
portrayal of black and latina women were
often posed in ways that were relatively
imposes that did not look powerful that
might even look submit
and asian-american women were often
depicted in ways that seemed
professional but somewhat somewhat
lacking in depictions of family life and
life outside of a career that could be
found in depictions of white women
essentially my project was to use
computational methods to try to find
patterns in the skin tones that appeared
in different issues of the magazine over
the 71 years that I chose to study from
1942 through December 2012 and the way
that I did this relied on relied on some
fundamental principles of how images are
represented for computers basically the
way an image is represented is based on
a color profile one of the particularly
common ones is RGB or red green blue
basically three values that show how
much red how much green and how much
blue should be in any one given pixel
with a set of values for each pixel in
an image in order to look specifically
at skin tone because a set of hues would
be difficult to quantify as
corresponding to exact skin tones of
people of different races I honed in on
a transformation of the RGB color
profile hue saturation value color which
it still represents the same types of
colors but one of the key difference is
that the three values it uses the first
defines what color is being shown the
second defines essentially how much of
the color that's saturation and the
third value is basically the brightness
so i looked at saturation of skin within
the images that i looked at in the vogue
magazine archive so my first task was
following up on a previous project by
Cristiano Wang with my advisor dr. Holly
rothmeyer I took a face detection
algorithm that Christy hadn't
successfully applied to the vogue
archive and use that to move in on my
real goal isolating areas of skin within
the images so the image here I used a
procedure called k-means segmentation to
split the image based on the way the
colors were grouped so that the top
image is a sum of the three images shown
below it basically my goal was to be
able to use camions segmentation and
then choose a single image to isolate
the skin tones within that in this case
that will be the middle image although
this led into the primary challenge i
saw in actually getting accurate results
it's relatively difficult for a computer
to help what is it is not skin in this
photo the particular challenge was that
mana was photographed in front foot
background that was similar to her skin
color in photographs with say a pure
white background the results would
probably be a lot easier to visualize
easier to say one of these is skin
particularly and the other two were not
but in going forward with this research
the main pieces that would need to be
improved in order to get results that
could actually have statistical
statistical significance and could lead
toward actual sociological commentary
about standards of beauty or racial
representation our first of all managing
things like the background and text
overlays which were pretty common in
photographs from the magazine and second
finding a way to choose among the
segments of the images more definitively
which one had skin and which one did not
I felt that saturation was a pretty good
means of judging the skin tone of a
person in a photo but because of the
complicating factors I mentioned
particularly background colors and text
overlays I wasn't at the end of the fall
semester able to produce any kind of
particular conclusive results however
hopefully this will be the beginning of
some future work on the Vogue magazine
archive and hopefully my data will be a
good starting point for future
researchers who can examine this in
greater depth thank
thanks very much grace and finally
Stephanie Valencia hello it's so great
to be here I got really excited about
this impose IAM because i've always had
this like to like worlds in my career
that's like art and engineering and i
found that they come together really
nicely when we talk about how can we
design for people of all abilities so i
work at the technology and innovation
lab at the yale child study center and
we explore how we can increase at the
well-being of people living with autism
spectrum disorders but i've also done
some work regarding like other
disabilities so first i well I would
like I would like to ask you this
question who can tell me for example the
answer to this question I know it's very
simple but if someone wants to answer it
i'll be happy five okay can somebody
tell me if there's another answer around
this question yes
this is exciting very true so there's
not only one answer to this question and
it all depends on how you look at it
right and sometimes when we have a
problem like how can we design for
people who are blind or how can we make
an image accessible for people who are
blind or how can we communicate emotion
to someone who is deaf and blind or how
can we communicate different things the
problems increasing complexity and there
are many answers some of the above
questions can be for example how can we
teach the color theory to people with
visual impairments or teach them about
graphic literacy and how can we even
understand how different people with
autism spectrum disorders recognize
emotion so there are different tools
that have been really helpful for me for
example the design thinking approach
this I'm thinking approach can be a
process of problem-solving through this
world researchers in the design area
trying to ask many questions do
observations and different exercises
that promote like divergent thinking to
then do an analysis of that and then a
synthesis and it goes it is a really
like long process of diverging and
converging and trying to come up with a
solution for these questions and then it
brings two disciplines together that
normally confront each other for example
engineering and art in engineering
engineers are more used to
problem-solving thinking how can we make
okay how can we solve this and maybe in
art we allow a more playful exploration
of this but they have a meeting point
and normal case illustration of this is
for example the prosthetic prosthetic
swirled engineers have different
approaches were they examine
biomechanics and it is very important to
know that this is functional but then in
art you can ask yourself how does a
prosthetic piece be part of the identity
of the person and how does these like
change our gives meaning to their lives
this is something they're wearing then
how can these be like significant and
how can this be tailored to embrace
different attitudes so the challenge of
disability is that there are different
ways we have to communicate information
because not everybody has the same
approach to the environment and they
have different sensing abilities and
this is important when we talk about
literature art and also inclusion so in
the middle of these two disciplines I
find that we have the ability to make
things so engineering fix the problem
solving part art brings the playful
exploration and they both meet in what
it is like a creation of products so I
just wanted to talk briefly just to get
you started about this thinking about
inclusion accessibility and disability
and three different examples that have
been important through my career so I
first wanted to explore how can we talk
about color in different ways and this
was with the population that have
different visual abilities and I was
thinking well how can we bring the color
conversation to them and I don't know if
it's gonna be uncomfortable it's gonna
be okay I would very naive approach but
then I started researching with an
artist cold Constanza Juanita and we
came up with this system that uses your
metric shapes tutitu the color theory so
for example we have the primary colors
yellow red blue and yellow as can be
straight lines like the sun's rays
there's like some come
behind the choosing we have a blue can
be like waves like the ocean and then we
can have green would be the straight
line in a wave so then this can lay the
foundation for different types of
expression and of sharing art through
touch another example is a project where
I use a human-centered design like a
method that concentrates on the user to
generate a product the question was how
can we increase graphic literacy in
children with visual impairments so
through a lot of playing with them and
looking at how they grab objects and how
they play we came up with different
prototypes that I can tell you more
about it later and finally with these
legs and sweet toy box well they can
explore different pieces and hear sounds
about them and this is of like a very
rough prototype but it was done with the
kids and it is very rich to like include
everybody when you're making something
and a final example of these is in our
lab at the deal we also explore social
robotics and we were exploring with
Sphero that this is like a commercial
robot how could we depict different
emotions through like movements lights
and sounds and see how the child's
reacted to the different combinations of
emotions and it was really interesting
at children word who are typically
developed and children with autism
reacted differently when the robot got
mad when we depicted sadness and it was
really nice to explore this because then
the question is how can we also
translate emotion what does emotion me
in two different people and all of these
are playful explorations that could turn
into interesting products or interesting
interventions and I'll leave you with
this one of my favorite quotes it's
about a designer called crab bullying
and he says that the issues around
disability are under explored and
we really need truly like
interdisciplinary design thinking
combining and blurring design craft with
engineering therapeutic excellence and
the experience of disabled people thank
you very much thank you so much
Stephanie and just thanks to everyone of
our lightning panelists I just like to
give all of you a round of applause all
excellent